Well, the next question that the privacy
policy should address is, you tell me
what you collect about me, so how do
you use this collected information?
What do you do about it or
what do you do with this information?
Google says they're collecting it to
really improve your user experience,
personalization search results that
they returned are the most relevant for
you, okay?
And you and I maybe have very
different kind of interests.
So even if you type the same
search query terms,
what the return could be different
because of this personalization.
So, the idea is the more we know about
you, the more information that we have
better is the experience that you
will have when you use their service.
And they make their money
by selling advertisements.
So the other thing that they
use your information for
is for serving targeted advertisements.
Although you can set preferences and
things like that.
But this information that we're
talking about, what they collect,
what you search for,
what sites you visit, things like that.
Well, that's all used to try to figure
out what kind of advertisements you
will be most interested in as
that's how they make their money.
So their information used
essentially to keep you hooked,
which is the good user experience,
personalized user experience.
And then be able to show you ads that
hopefully are of interest to you.